(BIRDS CHIRPING)
Hey y'all. We are back
and we are so excited
to wine down and talk
about this wild episode,
"High-Like."
And our very own Yvonne Orji
is back with us this week
-to get into it.
-Yeah!
This weekend was supposed to be
about two things,
female bonding and Beyoncé.
This was meant to be like
a girls-fun episode.
It was our first time,
this season,
that we really got to get
everybody together.
Episode three was like a nice,
little cute, little dinner.
But this was like,
the girls in their element.
-PRENTICE PENNY: Totally.
-Beyoncé or bust.
Beyoncé or bust!
If you're not
in your Beyoncé mode,
you're just busting in life.
You're bust-- You're losing.
-Ooh!
-Like, why would you--
-With the elongated "oohs?"
-ISSA RAE: Yeah.
It's like what would Jesus do
on Beyoncé or bust? Kinda like--
-Yeah, Beyoncé or bust.
-Copy.
I think it's the first time
that we actually see the girls
have a little bit of a hiccup
in their relationship.
'Cause usually,
when the girls are together,
either Issa or Molly is bringing
a problem to the group,
and the group is sorta weighing
in on those discussions.
What we always talked about,
is like, how do we see
-new dynamics of friendships?
-Yeah.
And it was nice to have that
Issa-Tiffany scene,
where it was just them
in the parking lot of 7/11.
We see Tiffany kinda be boujee
and throw a little shade.
But it was really nice.
I thought Amanda did such
an amazing job in that scene.
-Yeah.
-And you guys both
of being like,
"Aw, she's a real person.
She's really having concerns
and doubts.
And when she's not holding court
amongst all those things,
this is how she really is
and really feels."
And to me it made me understand,
"Oh, that's why they're friends
with her."
-Yeah.
-ISSA: And Tiffany,
we get to see her in a rare,
vulnerable moment of just like,
"Maybe I have to ask myself
if I'm okay with the fact that
we might not be friends
further."
-And to put that out there.
-Things will be different.
Things will be different
and I have to be okay with that.
And I think girls do that more
than guys,
'cause you'll see a group
of dudes, you'll be like,
"Why're you still friends
with him?" He be like,
"Aw man, I've known him since
I was eight." Well, un-know him!
-(LAUGHTER)
-Real talk, since you're a man,
and a real man does wear
this scarf.
I'm a man-- I'm a
bandana-wearing man. A real man.
Why do guys not...
exchange friends
when they make, like,
real-life decisions?
'Cause I think dudes feel
very loyal
to people who knew them
when they kinda had nothing.
I think this is where
men and women are different,
and I think that's what's
interesting about our show,
is that, I think,
men can have friendships that,
they'll say "that's my boy,"
but we don't really talk.
Where if a girl would say,
like "that's my girl," we talk.
And so I think the relationships
feels charged,
and more interesting
and more dynamic,
in a way that I think
men's friendships on--
-And certainly onscreen.
-Yeah.
Like even Lawrence,
like Lawrence in our show
of being a guy who was like--
got cheated on,
kinda became introverted
as opposed to,
if it was a woman,
they would talk it out,
-and sorta say why did he--
-Yeah.
-Like even in the museum
last season.
-Well, he tried to talk it out.
-He did! And his boys--
-He didn't have friends who're--
Will Lawrence ever have, like,
friends that are better?
Like, like is that something
we can help him with?
I think he has-- Chad's a--
-Chad is not a good friend!
-Chad's a loyal dude.
BOTH: He's loyal but he's not
a good friend.
Like Chad and Lawrence.
Why are they friends?
Ooh, speaking of Lawrence.
-He's back this episode.
-He came back this episode.
And it's gonna be
very interesting to see,
you know, what that means
for Issa, you know.
What was that moment like when
you saw Lawrence at the store?
Oh! It was, um...
It was a little reunion.
I got like butterflies
in my stomach of just like,
"Aw, he's back," because
Jay hadn't been on set.
Yeah.
Dun-duh-duh, surprise!
We got ya!
(LAUGHTER)
-Folks was trippin'!
-It was.
But seeing Chad
made my stomach turn.
'Cause I really-- I love Neil,
hate Chad.
But it was just--
It felt like a reunion and...
um, we're gonna see
next episode what that means.
But that was one of the things
we talked about too in the room,
was like, when do we
reintroduce Lawrence?
And when do we bring him back?
And I think what's interesting,
is, I think it was last season,
where it was like,
as soon as you get a guy,
bloop-bloop, here comes the exes
popping up.
BOTH: Yes! Yes!
And that's really what happens,
is like you're here with Nathan,
and then, bloop-bloop,
-here's Lawrence!
-Here comes Lawrence.
So, thanks for wining down
with us this week,
and thanks to the lovely,
as always, Yvonne Orji.
-Oh, thank you. Hey, boo!
-ISSA: Yes!
Cheers, cheers, cheers,
and we will see you next time.
So, I have a question.
Is that a bandana? Are you--
You know what? We don't need
to get into what this is.
-It's just--
-Are you Bloods or Crips?
You know what? I'm neutral.
-(CHUCKLING) Is that what it is?
-I ride both sides.
You know what? This is--
(MUTTERING)
(CACKLING)
-Prentice, come back!
-(PRENTICE SHOUTING)